did
it
[Music]
huh
there we go only a couple minutes late
uh
hello folks hope everyone is doing well
hello carowind hello Miss Wicked Wolf
homebody John Angus Robin M.C a Gozer
hope you had a good birthday
uh what age demo do you think the Mario
movie should be aimed at I feel like I'm
the youngest you can be and have much
Nostalgia for the original
four games hand me down SNES and I'm 30.
I mean
to me it makes the most sense to have it
aimed at a young demographic at
8 to 12 basically I mean construct it
well in other age groups will enjoy it
but that's kind of been the way that
Mario has always been handled Mario has
never done the Sonic thing of like
trying to grow with its audience and
trying to update to keep appealing to
the older fans they'd like no we're
gonna make it appealing to the same
demographic as always and if our old
fans haven't outgrown it they'll stick
around and I see no reason to approach
the movie any differently
ah
yeah I've yes Miss Wiggle well if I have
a number of re I've got three reactions
up in the break room I will have a
fourth later today because I swear I
swear the studios they
they all gang up and they're like how
many trailers can we release within a 48
hour period and you know what's really
annoying two of them are from the same
company
both Blue Beetle and Barbie are both
from freaking Warner Brothers
granted they're probably aimed at
different demos but still yeah yeah
hey
I love Mario I played it on the DS I
played Mario on the original Nintendo
[Music]
I could keep going I'll stop though
thank you Soh this was given to me by
somebody very special and I like it very
very much
violent this weekend that's someone I
went to high school with died ah yeah
that's always
that's always an awkward thing to find
out
let's see
grew up on Mario Brothers my brother
started with Donkey Kong oh boy that's
going back
haha
yep
jealous I can't whistle at all it's it's
apparently a rarer skill than I thought
it was I guess it's just because
everybody in my family always just could
whistle and I took to a pretty
easily I guess it just it never strikes
me that like other people can't
whistle well or whistle at all I can't
do the the I can't do that thing the
high pitch like get everybody's
attention whistle I never figured that
out but uh
please tell me if they're going to get
perscrat
Chris Pratt to recreate the if you do
drugs you go to hell before you die
please PSA uh I can't imagine that
they're going to do that
I mean look I think I think the um the
big unexpected shout out to Mario's past
that we got was the
I guess it counts as a trailer where
they had it was like it was like an
in-universe ad for Mario Brothers
Plumbing and they were singing the theme
song from the cartoon that also had the
live action segments
ah ah that was entertaining yes I know
Ms Wicked Wolf that's why it's a topic
of conversation
I can't whistle but I can't roll my
tongue I can do both of those
because if you can roll your tongue you
can purr
opinions on the casting of jinx Monsoon
and Doctor Who I have none
like I I think everybody expects me to
have an opinion because I'm queer in a
doctor who fan but the thing is I only
watch the first four seasons of dry
Grace and at which point does I decided
I'd had enough and didn't want any more
I think I've technically heard her do
some Voice work in a few places but
nothing that jumped out at me so
since I don't know what character she's
playing and I don't know any of her work
as an actor
uh I mean I'm you okay this gets weird
because I know I know it's they outside
of drag but Jinx Monsoon is also the
drag name so I don't know if which
pronouns I should be referring to them
with
I don't okay regardless
I'm having that weird moment I don't
even know what pronouns you people want
God I am getting old
um but like I haven't I have nothing to
base an opinion on
I haven't I haven't seen them do
anything nothing that stuck in my head
so I just I have no opinion I'll have an
opinion when I when I can see something
it's same reason I don't really have an
opinion on um
oh cripes Yasmin and her last name is
escaping me the the confirmed companion
for shooty
um
I don't really have an opinion on her
either because I haven't seen any of her
I don't even really have that much of an
opinion on shooty because I haven't seen
his stuff either
my opinion is I hope it's good
what's the weirdest request that I've
had on my other platform
um
I I don't think I can answer that
question I will get demonetized
answering that question
I would have to find a super coded way
to do it besides which it actually feels
odd for me to answer that question like
in all sincerity
I feel like
so
on the other platform in question
on the one that is uh exclusively
for fans
I I do take custom requests I mean
there's a premium charge for that but I
do take custom requests but the thing is
I don't
I feel like there's there's a
presumption of privacy and obviously not
to tell anyone who it is who's ordering
it not that I know anyway it's all
Anonymous in the accounts but I don't
know sharing what it was somebody wanted
as a private thing from me I don't know
it feels wrong for me to to say what
those are in general whether they're
weird or not some of them have been a
little weird not too many though
actually a surprise number of them have
been oddly sweet
which is nice some of them have been
decidedly not particularly sweet but
also you know within my own comfort and
uh preferences and limits
excuse me people have been very
respectful over there it's been nice
watched Carol for the first time last
night oh that's a good one Louise
a great Staffing movie hit me in the
fields how well it captured the
loneliness of being a lesbian it I mean
especially for the time period it's set
in yeah yeah that's a great movie I love
that movie
tell tell me about you want me to tell
you about my first experiences give me
as a baby child my I basically was
introduced to gaming in first grade
because I had a babysitter who brought
over his Nintendo and hooked it up to
the TV
and that was where I discovered Mario
and so
um wasn't too long after that my mother
got me a a Nintendo of my own and that
was it so you know around around age six
you know it's funny I convinced myself I
played the original four games but I
since found out I actually only ever
played the All-Stars version I mean I
was pretty close I mean like it's it's a
visual makeover but the All-Stars
version is pretty accurate remakes
weren't doing too much of the let's
alter the mechanics thing back in the
day
I watched trailer for the new Barbie I'm
not and I've I haven't seen it yet so
we're I'm not even gonna read the rest
of that I can lick my elbow oh that's
impressive
uh wait I'll drag performers don't know
each other no shockingly we don't nor do
all YouTubers nor even do all who tubers
know each other it's shocking I know
uh
see where was I
I'm glossing past comments about the
Barbie trailer because I haven't watched
it yet if you ever Miss Buffy don't but
don't feel like re-watching it the
eighth doctor book vampire science came
out in the same year as season two and
has similar themes somebody on Twitter
kept bringing that up I remember seeing
it in my feed that that a lot
oh
hey there Pirates good to see you
it's not a mollusk necklace no it's it's
kind of like
um
a uh
uh I guess like an
orchid flower petal might not be an
orchid it's it's sort of meant to be
kind of floor but I mean it's just it's
just a glass design I suppose in some
ways it's actually rather yonic but uh
we won't go too far down that whole part
of my language uh I'm up late getting
kit getting the kitchen ready for
Passat
so I appreciate the live stream for
somebody to listen to I'm boy I'm
pouring boiling water over so many
things well I I hope that it all goes
smoothly Margaret and I probably
mispronounced
whatever it is that you are preparing
for and I apologize for that
favorite Fourth Doctor Story City of
death
that see that one's easy that one is up
piece of cake
uh
uh what's your go-to Coffee or Starbucks
order I like the London Fog actually
it's kind of my go-to if it's available
can I Whistle and roll my tongue at the
same time I have never tried I doubt it
I'm not gonna try live on stream because
if it doesn't work I'm gonna look dang
foolish
says if I don't look foolish anyway
first game I remember playing was joust
on the Atari so I I did play Atari a
little bit I didn't have an Atari but I
had friends who did who like had older
stuff you know had gotten stuff second
hand
um and couldn't afford the newer games
but I did play it I've actually played
E.T on the Atari
the notorious E.T I have indeed played I
remember playing the the two-player tank
game is the one that I played uh I
remember playing the most
do do
do do do do do
John vinyls thank you very much
[Laughter]
are we doing uh
we doing singing parodies now
I Wanna Be Where the witches are
I wanna see wanna see him casting
casting the Spells with them what do you
call them
oh glyphs
[Laughter]
[Music]
passage AKA Passover ah gotcha
I I figured it was something like that I
just like
I can't keep track of this stuff and I
also never know when it's coming up like
I
I remember living in New York
repeatedly having Ash Wednesday catch up
on me and like out of nowhere being like
why do all these people have like this
dirt on their face oh right that thing
I may have been that person on Twitter I
reviewed it last month so it came up a
fair but oh well there we go Ben
my go-to order is a caramel macchiato
preferred hot but we'll have iced
I tend to favor hot
what is a London Fog a London Fog is
it's basically
um it's kind of a latte but with black
tea instead of coffee
be the easiest way to describe it that's
probably not actually fully accurate but
it'll give you the gist of it
what does Vermont look like in
comparison to Wednesday
um it's not nearly that flat for
starters like the you
other than a couple of spots that have
that were flattened four roads like
brief stretches of Highway you cannot
find a Mile Stretch in Vermont that is
not
a significant Hill
and when I say significant I mean like
if you haven't worked out lately good
luck biking all the way up to the top of
the damn thing Vermont is not a flat
place that that setting was
quite flat I didn't pay particular
attention but they were probably the
wrong kind of trees if I were to look
closer and just the general Vibe of it
just and honestly it weirded me out that
they did this whole thing where like
oh and we have this statue to our
Pilgrim hat wearing founder I'm like
this is a Massachusetts thing we don't
do that here towns of Massachusetts to
do stuff like that we don't do that here
first video game I played was probably
Lemmings oh
oh but I had a friend who added on uh on
PC
getting drunk nope
just getting happy
forget your troubles come on get happy
we're gonna chase all your kids away
shout hallelujah come on get happy
get ready for the Judgment Day
this is a Singh heavy uh stream
apparently I'm all about Dragon drink
with Paradise drink as backup but if I
could get a
uh trianta chai latte I'd be on that in
a heartbeat ooh nice choices
you know what's my earliest memory of
games watching my big brother play with
his friends bro can I have a turn maybe
later
oh yeah
yep that's
I'll tell you what I I one of the many
reasons that I was happy to be an only
child I did not have to give somebody
their turn unless I had a friend coming
over and even then I tended to favor uh
co-op games if we were both gonna play
something you know what this is tilted a
little up for my taste let's bring that
down
just a smidge
there we go
that's better
uh
the Chun
is like the green break and I'm probably
butchering that too like I could
probably do it okay if I heard it like I
just I'm huh
I think my first game might technically
have been Quake oh good grief that or
where in the World is Carmen San Diego
uh my first uh my first computer game I
had was where in the USA as Carmen San
Diego
where in the World is Carmen San Diego
uh let's see
hate to say I work at Starbucks but
hardly ever get to make London Fog so I
always forget what's in them besides
Earl Gray and steamed milk
[Laughter]
fair enough not enough people will
appreciate it
Dharma once joke to me in DMS that
Vermont is 90 vertical
oh maybe more like 75
because you know we have lakes those are
flat
[Laughter]
but yeah it's
the weirdest experience for me when I
found myself out in the Midwest and I
don't want to explain why but I found
myself driving on a highway like in
Indiana
and it was just flat all the way to the
horizon
it
felt surreal in a really unnerving way
like I felt deeply uncomfortable I'm
like
give me a hill give me a mountain like
give me just a natural speed bump
something
Vermont I suppose the clue is in the
name well yeah
yeah it's it's a mashup of terms for
green and Mountain because it's the
Green Mountain State hey
only game I play is Sims honestly I
never could get into the Sims I think
it's because they're not goal oriented
enough it's too free form
like I've gotten into
um stardew Valley
a little bit but it helps that that game
you know has clear goals you know clear
things to progress to you know uh
you know goals and targets and you know
work work to get this and
Sims you know has you know keep your
Sims happy or whatever but like as
that's too vague that's too vague for me
John vinyls once again thank you very
much doesn't the name Vermont Mean Green
Hills ever seen any blue hedgehogs or
Titans uh we don't talk about that
Green Hill Zone oh good grief
no drunks tonight still have to work
that's correct Carolyn I it's just the
one I promise
I'll behave
mostly
ah
that was such a good oh thank you
Carolyn I wondered if you'd catch with
me singing that
what musical would I be in if I had a
choice Rocky Horror Picture Show or next
to normal
either one of those I'd really like Dan
and Next To Normal is I I think at this
point my last remaining
male character I really want to play
because the other ones that are like
technically men are like I'll play it
but I'm gonna gender bend it
you can't with Dan I still want to play
him
uh
oh that shows real good
what are my thoughts on the ending of
the second Wizard of Oz book I never
read it so I couldn't tell you
uh
if we got a proper Doctor Who Star Trek
crossover you mean other than the one
that happened in the comics because that
has happened which doctor and crew would
you want to see interact I go 12th
doctor on either the Enterprise E or the
uh saratos
um
[Music]
I kind of would like to see Capaldi
clash with uh
with Pike
and the strange new worlds crew
and I realized the movie land before
time is 35 years old this year
good Lord
you say breakfast oh good
uh I think my first computer game was
number crunchers oh yes the stuff the
stuff that that we were told was
educational
it wasn't really
uh
uh they've announced who's playing uh
Santiago in Interview with the Vampire
season two it's Ben Daniels who is a
long time partner of Ian gelder who
played zelen
okay I had I haven't gotten to that show
so like I don't have a lot of
I have a lot to go off of there and I
don't know how far they got
any thoughts on Invincible comic and or
series no because I have neither seen
nor read it
uh
ah see
driving across Kansas talk about flat I
believe it
yeah
have I ever babysat for anyone new
nope because because when it's your own
kid it's not called babysitting anymore
then it's just parenting
so no no I never really to babysit
anyone
you'd be deeply unnerved by the
Netherlands yeah probably
a friend introduced me to in the early
2000s and called it electric Barbie
dolls and that's what got me hooked
oh for The Sims yeah that's
that is that is not an awful descriptor
actually
yeah it's uh
yeah you build your dream house
ah
let's see
I remember finding out one of my
brother's friend had a N64 when I was
four I was like wow did his family win
the lottery or something uh the N64 my
I had access to one of those pretty
early into its release
there weren't a ton of games when it
first came out but Mario 64. if you were
there when it first came out Mario 64
really kind of blew my mind when I was
young
I'd love to be in little shop before as
if I was a better actor or a better
singer oh yeah
oh yeah sure I could actually uh get any
of these parts if I auditioned for them
no Brandon I haven't seen the Barbie
trailer yet I'm probably gonna do a
reaction video to it after the Stream
my favorite stardew towns person oh
there's a couple I like I like Pam
um I like Abigail a lot
um
those are kind of the ones that I'm like
oh and I oh I like Linus Linus is great
I love him
most of them are sweet some of them I
don't like some of the guys some of the
teenage guys and Haley annoys the hell
out of me
um but you know there's some nice ones
in there I went back and watched your Ms
Marvel reviews and definitely agree it
should have been longer moved on to
Hawkeye I'm really enjoying it so far
just one episode to go I'd say Hawkeye
is probably for me second to Loki in
terms of how well it came out
uh
I think that was my reaction to when I
found out where I was 10 when it was
released
[Laughter]
I had Land Before Time on VHS as a child
I saw it in the theaters
I didn't cry as a kid I cried
re-watching it as an adult that's one of
the funny things about going back and
watching kids media with sad stuff
because a lot of it doesn't hit until
you have a frame of reference of what
it's like to have
a deep loss
and when you're six which I would have
been
you don't really have that framework
like you understand oh that's sad
and maybe you even feel a little bit sad
but like
re-watching that movie as an adult it
wrecks me it's oh boy
John vinyls coming in once again thank
you so very much ever thought about
doing a ranking of Don Bluth movies plus
Dragon's Lair I know you love and adore
secret of nim I am not considering that
because there are too many of his Latter
Day
uh stuff basically most of his 90s stuff
that I just haven't seen and don't
really want to
like I don't want to watch troll in
Brooklyn
I don't want to watch The Swan Princess
I don't want to watch Thumbelina
I'm pretty sure those are him
I don't want to watch uh Rock-a-Doodle
like I
and maybe some of them I would like but
I know some of them are going to be a
slog and I don't want to take the time
to go through all that I mean is why
doing God it was years ago now but it
was why doing a ranking on say Miyazaki
movies was easy I'd already seen them
the only one I had to go out of my way
to watch so I could do that list was
castle of cogliostro I'd already seen
all the rest of them
Tara staller thank you so much for the
Super Chat fun fact princess osma from
The Wizard of Oz books has a gender
bending story arc I did know that I
don't
I don't know the story arc well but Liz
really liked those books so when we were
still together she would tell me a
little bit sometimes about some of the
Bonkers stuff that goes on in them and
she did mention that to me so I do kinda
know about that
Disney's gonna remake The Aristocats and
Bambi into live act like
it really does show how
bereft
of
um faith in new ideas they are I'm not
gonna say they're bereft of new ideas I
bet you yes they're creative leads
they've got ideas they just
top wrestling greenlit them
uh have you ever very long shot here uh
encountered the French rock opera star
Mania it's a compelling tangle of
Kick-Ass music and many times Rewritten
plot
thank you
the addition uh
uh Rogue is great A Rouge wrote the
addition Rouge is great uh I have not
seen it I have not heard of it did I
play Ocarina of Time I did I did play it
played it and beat it back in the day
probably couldn't play it now probably
made me motion sick now
I despise Pierre who doesn't Pierre's a
bit of a jackass in stardu yeah Elliot
yeah Elliott has that snooty thing going
for him
yes
I like poetry and I live in a cabin by
the sea
because he's got like long flowing locks
and nonsense yeah I'm not a huge fan of
Elliot the thing is I run into Elliot so
infrequently that I actually don't think
too much about him
so that makes life slightly easier
I enjoy Hawkeye 100 because of Yelena
Elena is awesome
Elena is really fantastic I am excited
for more of her
I agree carowind Pierre does need to get
his head out of the cash register and
pay attention to Caroline either that or
Caroline's got to find herself a nice
side piece and he needs to turn he needs
to come to terms with being a cuckold
which you know as long as it's
consensual no shame but
got to see live touring production of
Les Miserables and
um I'm not usually a musical girl but it
was damn impressive I mean like
that show especially live that that show
fills the space it is a big show it
feels big it plays big the music's big
it's easy to get wrapped up in
Land Before Time hits me more now
because I have kids so it seem a little
food little foot some other wrecks me
yeah exactly
whoo
uh the criminally underrated proper bird
has a video called is our future a
dystopia that I think you might really
dig maybe I mean my immediate re my
immediate answer to that is our present
is a dystopia what are you talking about
but you know that's also me being out of
uh F's to give
I have no more what's the news
let's see so the biggest problem with
Hogwarts Legacy is the clout JKR gets
how does pirating help that
if you are not a streamer
and you are not playing it publicly
and you did not pay money for it
then I feel that pirating largely
mitigates that if you are a streamer
especially if you are a streamer of
significant size then how you got the
game doesn't really matter
I saw Shazam too today they fixed
something I thought was dumb in the
first movie
um
in this one the oldest sibling just
plays herself in both forms since the
actor is an adult even if the character
is a kid huh
interesting
yeah I don't have a lot of interest in
Shazam too
would you consider making a video about
ethically navigating fandoms it feels
like it's harder than ever these days
I'm not sure I ever would Timothy
partially because I don't really have
answers
I don't despite my job
and despite what you would think I don't
actually
um interact with fandoms very much I I
mean I deal with fandoms to the ascent
of they show up in my comment section
but
even Doctor Who which I love the closest
I come to engaging in fandom is when I
go to Gallifrey one
the actual
um you know things you know fandom
spaces and forums and subreddits and fan
fiction and you know those kinds of fan
spaces which in many ways are the heart
of modern fandom
I really don't engage with them and it's
not even because like oh it's too
difficult to navigate I just
ADHD I can't commit to like my time to
that I've got other stuff to do
it's called the troll in Central Park
and Swan Princess was not Don Bluth ah
figured I probably got some of that
right
the Stage production of My Neighbor
Totoro was the big winner at the Olivier
Awards the other night there is a Stage
production of My Neighbor Totoro
foreign
why
I mean if it exists I'm glad it's good
but
why
ah whatever
John vinyls once again do you prefer
Disney Renaissance Era on 88 to 99 or
Disney Revival era 2010 to the present
ah I honestly
think that the current ERA has yielded
more
really good movies
uh than the Renaissance did the
Renaissance started really strong
because you had
you had
um Little Mermaid and you had Beauty and
the Beast and you had Aladdin and you
had Lion King
and then it was Pocahontas and then it
was just kind of a
[Music]
downward trajectory with uh
just diminishing returns as it went
let's see
that's that like I love some of the
Disney Renaissance stuff but I feel like
the Revival era also has had its good
movies more spread out
you know they weren't just like all
crammed in the front end the way the
Renaissance was
uh all I will say is the news of the new
Harry Potter TV show is that if there's
ever a time for Scott Buck to show run
now is that time
did he ever
did he ever get back to work after he
crashed the Inhumans
I gotta check that
Scott buck
Jim
oh those are writing credits produce
nope
[Music]
since then humans
you didn't even he didn't even work on
the second season of Iron Fist
oh he kind of was my Arch TV my arch
rival in TV for a while
ah
[Music]
OSP have two wonderful episodes of
detailed diatribe on Superman that I
highly recommend I've listened to those
they're quite good
oh Dharma sweet 16 months of being a
snazzy supporter thank you for your
continued membership I greatly
appreciate it
I have no more F's to give song is the
text dome for group text which one of my
best friends which is why my phone is
usually on silent in public well my
phone's on silent just instinctively
like I've I've never assigned songs to
you know ring on certain people because
I my phone's just always set to vibrate
um have I played any other zeldas if so
which do I like I've okay so I played a
few of the zeldas I played the original
original I played
um
I played Zelda II Lynx Adventure uh I
played link to the past which is the
best one
um I played Minish Cap I played Link's
Awakening I played Ocarina of Time I
didn't beat all of these but I didn't
play all these I played Majora's Mask I
played Wind Waker and I played
Phantom Hourglass
and I played a tiny bit of
um
Twilight Princess
that was the last one
do I have a blue rain DVD collection but
of course
uh Angus
talking of Florence Pew have you seen
mid-somar or any of Ari Esther's other
work not yet I don't think I've seen any
of them
I haven't seen mid uh mid-summer
um
I'm trying to remember if I've seen any
of his other stuff I don't think I have
no no
no I haven't as yet
fathom events is going to be showing the
stage version of spirits Spirited Away
you gotta say to what is
what is go
let animated projects be animated just
just leave them alone
what about Bambi's mom I actually
haven't re-watched Bambi as an adult
although to my memory it's not like
the fact of it is sad but like the
specifics of How It's executed I
wouldn't imagine what hit me as as hard
uh in orbit I did see the Jinx Monsoon
news I talked about it earlier insofar
as I have no opinion because I am not
really familiar with Jinx monsoon
I like my neighbor tots Robert White
kind of messed me up not gonna lie first
Miyazaki movie I saw was
um
why am I suddenly drawing Princess
Mononoke was the first one I saw
that's good stuff
aside from the portrayal of the Siamese
cats what's wrong with The Aristocats
it's boring
the characters aren't enjoyable I don't
like spending time with them and the
villain sucks
forgot to mention Rescuers Down Under I
couldn't remember if that hit an 88 or
if it was just before
I loathed Pocahontas I still haven't
seen Pocahontas there's a couple from
the Renaissance Era I still haven't seen
I haven't seen Pocahontas and some
people are going to get mad at me with
this one I still haven't seen hunchback
Meg wants to watch that one with me so
that'll that'll probably happen
eventually
is it bad that I like Pocahontas
I know I don't think so I haven't seen
it so
any thoughts on Pearl Mudder getting the
boot about damn time that's literally
all I have to say
you have what we call a filthy laugh
Thang Q
I don't know
is Agent Carter worth watching
um it was fine
it left very little impression on me but
it was fine
uh do you regret the fact 2D theater
Film Production is kind of dead
uh outside Japan I mean
do I regret it regret would mean it it
would have to be somewhat my fault do I
would I prefer that were not the case
yes I would very much prefer that to not
be the case
I'm gonna try and catch up uh because I
know I've got
stuff to get to Supreme
Omega a modern superhero comics and
media in general
um do you think they have ignored the
civilian side of superheroes with less
emphasis on normal supporting characters
well yeah
because at this point any normal
supporting cast member you wait long
enough they will either end up dead or
they will end up with powers
because
writers get bored or run out of ideas
was my favorite Stephen King movie
adaptation
um
Stand By Me
I haven't watched and know almost
nothing about Loki is there something
about Quantum media I'm not getting
um well if you've seen Quantum medium
but haven't seen Loki
no not exactly but you would have
already known who Kang was
if you had seen Loki but I think
quantumania explains it well enough that
you're okay
excuse me
my first Ghibli was Kiki's Delivery
Service oh nice
it Rescuers Down Under came out in 90.
ah that is an underrated movie hope this
isn't too much of a shop question do you
announce commissioned reviews in my
schedule I if you look at the bottom of
the docket
if there's a commissioned review that I
believe I will get to that month it will
be listed in the bottom with the stuff
that is planned for the break room
uh that doesn't have a specific release
date just because it isn't there doesn't
mean that I won't get to commissioned
reviews that month but you know that's
that is the closest I come to
[Music]
um
to announcing those in advance by and
large
John vinyls is Edgar the worst Disney
villain
um
it might be he's up there for sure
I think my first Jubilee was the fox
release of Totoro ah Sodom bootle got a
con interesting
Tom Scott just released a video ranking
all the times All-Star has been used to
movies I know I've already seen it that
was fun Thomas got does fun stuff
ah
somebody once told me the world is Gonna
Roll me
I ain't the sharpest tool in the shed
thank you for the Discord reminder
um Carolyn let me catch up on the Super
Chat that's here and waiting and I'll do
that Supreme Omega on the RTD era of
Doctor Who thoughts on Davies focusing
on the civilian side of companions like
rose Marth and Donna do you feel it
worked no not to the extent that he did
it I have referred to that in past as
the domestics side and no because I want
to see the doctor and the companion rush
off on the Tardis too far in exotic
places and odd points in time and I
don't like that they have to keep coming
back to Earth for
um
you know soap opera drama level nonsense
it worked a little bit with rose because
it was kind of Novel it had never really
been done before not a lot was done with
Martha's family yet we kept coming back
to them Donna worked the best I suppose
but it was only because wilf was so
amazing
so that one lucked out that the specific
characters were really good and like
that continued on into Moffat Sarah I
had actually say the worst offender was
Clara
um initially because
series 8 especially the doctor I had to
kept just coming back to Earth because
she wouldn't just travel with him
like it it was explained there was a
reason she had to you know she had a job
and she had Danny and whatnot those were
good things for her as a character but
in terms of tying it back to Earth no
anyways I gotta go to the Discord
reminder the Discord the Council of
geese Discord is a patreon exclusive
perk
um and people get to ask me questions on
there that I am guaranteed to address
without necessarily having to engage
with these super chats though I
appreciate all the super chats all right
oh we got a few I will get through these
as quick as I can
should we only give movies credit for
representation if it's done in a way
that isn't easily removed when the movie
is shown in other countries I went to
see Shazam 2 today and they reveal one
of Shazam one of the Shazam kids is gay
but the thing is it only comes up in two
scenes and it's not at all relevant to
the plot I contrast another one of the
straight kids has all romance subplot
where he falls in love with one of the
villains and gets her to change sides I
mean which of these is easier to edit
out all right short version of my answer
to that is
yes we should still give credit for that
we should not give as much and we should
still call out when it is easily
removable however I am fond of saying I
would rather have
too small or even not particularly good
representation than no representation
because when there's something there you
can make it better when there's nothing
there what the hell are you supposed to
do so like I think some credit should be
given not a massive hat on the back be
like that's nice that that's there it's
annoying and within the same breath it's
annoying that it's so easily cut like I
think I think it is possible to both say
thank you for doing that but also for
next time maybe you know and give notes
could you enjoy a show where sometimes
uh
that where they sometimes use a
character being perverted as a source of
humor or would that be a deal breaker
for you recently I've been watching an
anime called uh mushuko tensei which is
about a shut-in who dies and gets
reincarnated as a wizard in a fantasy
world it's pretty good in a lot of ways
but in the earlier episodes It's a
running joke the protagonist keeps
perving on women and getting away with
it because he's in a toddler's body they
assume he doesn't know what he's doing
whether or not I would be able to
continue on with a show that did that
depends on the frequency and whether or
not I am meant to find it funny
endearing or otherwise be okay with it
because the thing with many things like
that it the problem isn't that shows do
it it's that they do it without
examination which implies that you're
supposed to just find it entertaining
and I don't I find it gross so if I'm
not meant to find the character
especially endearing if it's something
that the show is going to address or if
it is dropped quickly I could probably
be okay but as a recurrent thing it
could very well sour me on something
yeah
do you think little boys who dislike
girls are particularly likely to grow
out of that attitude at some point when
people on that my hero Academia
subreddit were telling me all boys hate
girls they were implying it's a thing
they also grow out of do they grow out
of it or do they realize it's not
socially acceptable to go around saying
girls are smelly and start expressing
misogyny in more subtle ways I think
none of this is inherent to boys I think
all this is socially learned behavior
and
um
by and large on a surface level yes uh
boys who are like ooh girls are icky
many of them will grow out of it but it
will be on the basis of oh girls are hot
and it doesn't necessarily represent an
actual uh gaining of appreciation or
respect but sometimes it does sometimes
it doesn't
um but like none of these attitudes are
ingrained none of them are inherent none
of them are natural these are socially
conditioned Notions it's all nonsense
uh what simply put is the reason for
your dislike of the new 52 run at DC
sparing you the whole entire rant that I
could go on about the new 52 shortest
version it was unnecessary it was not
needed there was nothing that was of
value that was done that could not have
been done within the existing continuity
and everything that they did that
couldn't be done within the existing
continuity was stuff they shouldn't have
been doing that's why
what is one fantasy Trope you wish you
could get rid of right now for added
difficulty no chosen one or true destiny
tropes ah you know me
um ancient relics
I'm really tired of uh like like I like
a good treasure hunt story broadly
speaking but I'm really tired of we must
find this ancient relic of power or the
villains have uncovered the sanctuary
why is ancient stuff always so super
crazy powerful why can't new stuff be
good
anyone who's ever read my book there are
tiny hints that they're being
um ruins around but like
any old stuff that you find it's not
going to be of any value what kind of
non-speculative fiction words do you
like to consume when you can example I
love reading or watching detective
fiction and Caper's stories when not
reading fantasy or sci-fi
um I mean fantasy and sci-fi are just
always my go-to I can enjoy uh a good
mystery story like a good murder mystery
but I have to be in the mood for it
um that's kind of the closest to a go-to
the rest are just like random things
that just struck my fancy one time
what is your opinion of those far left
Scandinavian groups that are trying to
legalize incense and necrophilia what
are your thoughts on legalizing
victimless crimes more victimless crimes
more generally
uh okay I know nothing about this so I'm
going to keep any discussion to a
minimal because I'm going to try and
avoid forming any kind of strong opinion
on something that I honestly have no
idea what you are talking about
um
victimless crime especially for talking
about incest uh that's very dicey
because there is a power dynamic in play
and very very very very very very very
very often almost every time there is an
aspect of somebody grooming or otherwise
taking advantage of another person so
even if you have both parties saying
that it is consensual there's still
something wrong with the inherent power
Dynamic it's like how a professor
starting to have sex with their student
and I say Professor like even at the
college level that's messed up even if
both are like we both want this the
power Dynamic is messed up and makes it
basically impossible for this to be
engaged in ethically in the power
Dynamic you are currently in
um necrophilia had
I don't even I don't even know how to
begin to wrap my head around the idea of
legalizing that I suppose if I were to
go completely like
pragmatic on it
it is really just social mores
that keep that from being allowed but
I do not feel okay with the fact that I
said that
so whether you want to chalk that up to
just having the idea of it being really
unsettling be too deep ingrained for me
to fully detach from or just maybe there
is something more inherently wrong with
that Beyond just my own visceral factor
and I'm just not able to quantify it
right now I don't know that is a weird
question I just dealt with do you think
it's good that Kingpin seems to have
ditched the fat suit for the new season
of Daredevil I feel as though it gives
them a sense of physicality in season
one and three that made it more
believable to think you could go
toe-to-toe with Daredevil although I can
see how using a fat suit to code someone
as a threat can be problematic well the
Kingpin
the Kingpin is an uh is an odd character
when it comes to Fat representation
because canonically it's not fat it's
muscle I mean like there is some fat
there he's not trim but like what fat
you see is over pounds and pounds and
pounds of muscle
so Kingpin is weird to talk about as a
piece of fat representation because the
canonical explanation for why he is the
way he is already kind of subverts
normal fat character tropes but at the
same time everything about his visual
coding is fat it's weird it's hard to
it's hard to say I mean in general I
don't think fat suit should be used by
and large at all
um if you can avoid it so
uh what do you think is harder to get
into
a show that has just been canceled after
one season or one that has so many
seasons that'll take months for you to
catch up to the last one depends did the
show that was canceled after one season
was it directly set up to have more
seasons or does it contain a largely
self-contained and fulfilling story if
the latter that should be easy I'm
assuming you mean the former though
um and which would make it more
difficult honestly
I would probably have a harder time
getting into a show that only had one
season that I know
I'm gonna hit if I like it the best case
scenario is I like it I hit the end and
go boy I'm real sad there isn't more and
I'm not that's a hard thing to psych
myself up to do
oh here it is
what are your thoughts on Harry Potter
being rebooted as an HBO Max show short
version I think it is incredibly telling
about the state of Warner Brothers
Discovery as a company and of Harry
Potter as a property I will not be going
into detail on it because that
is going to be Saturday's video I
actually shot it earlier today
so personally I'm tired of money and
resources being wasted on reboots when
there are so many great books to be
adapted Harry Potter movies were
Timeless and had the best cast and
honestly I don't think a series will be
able to match the quality of those films
where the film's 100 accurate No but
honestly who cares I also hate that this
will make JK Rowling even more relevant
and give her more of a platform I mean
that's always in the mix at this point
like that's a given I don't want to live
through Tenors so here's a bigotry turn
ending every day I almost wish someone
would start working on a huge production
uh Pro LGBT show as resistance this
would never happen but imagine uh Matrix
prequel spin-off or even remake that ex
that's explicitly queer and brings back
the Hong Kong fight choreography being
green lit because the wachowskis want to
be Petty definitely wouldn't happen but
a girl could dream is that is that too
long well I read all of it so I guess
not I mean one could argue that in some
ways the owl house was the queer
antidote
to Harry Potter
uh final question in the annals of
pointlessness is there anything more
pointless than the seemingly planned
remake of Moana featuring The Same Stars
I mean ultimately The Lion King remake
was probably more pointless
but yeah I saw that news I'm like that
has to be a joke that has to be like an
onion headline or something and then I
look into them like ah
sugar honey iced tea
ah
yeah
oh boy
anyways what have we got oh I've got a
couple of uh super chats to get to to
the mcu's credit they're pretty good at
explaining things in their movies for
the benefit of people who haven't seen
every movie or show largely it's getting
more complicated though
uh Supreme Omega also on the civilian
side of Heroes I wonder if the reason
why the old Spidey Comics got away with
it was because Peter had a strong
Supporting Cast
um I mean he had one of the better
civilian support supporting casts going
for a while
but even there eventually it went long
enough and what I mentioned kind of
happened
most of them died got powers or became
villains or some combination thereof
I don't know if you remember this but
incest is socially acceptable in the
culture I think bank's rationale was
well power imbalances just don't exist
in my Utopia I think I remember that
coming up it wasn't a major plot point
so I kind of breezed past it and the
bits that I
uh saw
or read or heard or what it like
uh
my brain works
ah so anyways
I
it's incest is one of those things that
like it always strikes me as weird
when certain writers
try to come up with reasons why it's
okay
like how about you just don't do it
it's like when you read or see something
that puts all this emphasis into like oh
these two characters grow up together
one of them's adopted though because you
know they're ultimately gonna hook them
up but I'm like the relationship Dynamic
is still siblings that's still messed up
how about you just not
it always it always strikes me as weird
when they do that anyways yes thank you
for the reminder to Hype stuff Carolyn I
appreciate that very very much and I
appreciate you always
so ah what do we got
so tomorrow I will be on Twitch I will
be playing uh more of uh super lesbian
animal RPG which is great I am loving
that game
um
so there'll be more of that
there will probably be another freaking
trailer reaction out either later this
evening or tomorrow morning in the break
room before the Barbie trailer because
too many damn trailers
um Saturday as I said is going to be
about the uh planned Harry Potter
uh TV series that'll be uh here
and yeah that's the stuff that's coming
up in the immediate so
cool
I think that's everything
um got any thoughts on Alan Moore not
being a fan of Lord of the Rings or Game
of Thrones not knowing his full quote no
I have no opinion uh can I say something
before you go you'll have to make it
quick but yeah sure go ahead
ah I mean Alan Moore is just one of the
grumpiest human beings on the planet
at this point I'm not sure he likes
anything anymore
uh thank you everybody for joining hope
you have a great night I completely
forgot about the problematic stuff in
the rat race
that's at the Barbie Museum guy was
pretty funny I haven't seen that movie
in ages I only saw it once I barely
remember it
oh well
I I don't I don't think it was one that
I really needed to uh
particularly
words words are hard today particularly
burn into my brain
foreign
there we go
let me just finish this off and we shall
call it a night
so yeah I hope to see some of you folks
on the twitch stream tomorrow
um it's always fun yeah I don't know how
many more streams I'll get out of super
lesbian animal RPG I'm hoping it'll be
the next two at least the remainder of
this week don't know what I'm gonna play
after that
gotta figure that out
all right
whoo
so
I avoided that in my question
deliberately
um hold on 255 A.D I think something ah
there it is it had filtered your
question for some reason I don't like
that you include an assumption that uh
that boys are that
that boys wouldn't say bad things about
girls because they just want sex
I I don't know what to tell you
I think that
for most young men raised in a situation
where they are encouraged to go ooh you
girls are gross I think for most of them
the point at which that opinion is going
to turn is when they start feeling an
attraction now does that mean that they
inherently only see them as sexual
objects or that it is a particularly
gross perspective no not necessarily it
can still lead to ultimately a mature
perspective but I based off my
experience my own lived experience and
observation
I don't know what else to tell you
I mean you need to remember I'm not
when I talk about young boys I don't
talk about it uh
uh outside of the context of knowledge
of personal experience
so I'm sorry if you don't like some of
my answers
I am answering your questions to the
best of my ability I don't know what
else to tell you
I don't like viewing men as inherently
more sex driven that wasn't necessarily
what I was saying
I think I was crass in the way that I
put it
but
ah
speaking of someone who has felt the
impact of
testrogen testrogen estrogen estrogen on
my mind my way of thinking versus
testosterone
um I do feel comfortable in saying that
by and large
men are often more sex-driven not
exclusively not entirely
but frequently
so
I'm sorry if you don't like thinking of
it that way I'm sorry if you don't like
that I think of it that way but again
I'm gonna give you the answer from the
perspective that I have
that's the only perspective I can offer
anyways that went on to a weird note at
the end of this we're gonna wrap it up
thank you everybody for joining me so I
hope that you all have a great rest of
the week I hope that you um enjoy
whatever it is you have planned I hope
to see you for other stuff going on and
um I hope that you be well be safe and
be kind and remember that you are
beautiful you're valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
mckevity